la guerre en Ukraine a enclenché un
processus de modernisation de l'armée
allemande le chancelier Olaf Scholtz a
annoncé en février 2022 alloué un fond
spécial de 100 milliards d'euros pour
transformer la Bundes verts alors que
vaut vraiment l'armée allemande
[Musique]
l'armée allemande est classée 25e dans
le classement mondial GFP bien loin
derrière d'autres pays européens comme
la France classée 9e l'Italie 10e ou
même encore la Pologne classée 20e
par des problèmes de fonctionnement
interne et d'équipements disponibles et
par beaucoup de limites dans son emploi
qui tiennent beaucoup à l'histoire du
pays à la fin de la guerre froide dans
les années 1990 s'impose dans le débat
politique en Allemagne le thème des
dividendes de la paix il apparaît plus
logique de réduire les dépenses dans le
domaine de la défense pour les investir
dans d'autres missions de l'État et dans
les années 2000 le gouvernement cherche
encore à réduire ses déficits début des
années 2000 on disait que l'Allemagne
était l'homme malade de l'Europe en
raison de ses différents déficits donc à
l'entreprise un vigoureuse d'effort de
de stabilisation de ses finances et pour
cela elle a réduit ses dépenses et l'un
des secteurs qui a le plus souffert
c'est la défense il faut rappeler que le
développement de l'armée allemande est
soumis à un cadre très clair
Bundes qui a la main le contrôle sur les
missions les opérations de l'armée
allemande donc c'est pas du tout comme
aux États-Unis ou en France ou même en
Grande-Bretagne ou le pouvoir politique
peut décider rapidement
d'un déploie militaire ça prend beaucoup
de temps en Allemagne depuis la fin de
la guerre froide l'Allemagne a largement
réduit les effectifs de son armée si on
pouvait compter 500.000 soldats au
moment de la réunification en 1990 on en
compte à peine 200 000 aujourd'hui quant
au matériel l'armée allemande dispose
d'équipements de qualité elle dispose
d'un char de bataille le léopard 2 qui
est un excellent chat et qui est un char
particulièrement apprécié puisqu'il a
été aussi beaucoup vendu dans un certain
nombre de pays européens notamment
membres de l'Alliance atlantique elle a
développé avec la France l'hélicoptère
de combat tigre qui est aussi un
excellent hélicoptère elle a elle a
disposée pendant longtemps comme
véhicule de blindés de combat
d'infanterie du Marder qu'elle est en
train de remplacer par un nouveau
véhicule qui est le puma donc elle a je
dirais sur le papier en tout cas des
équipements de qualité mais ces
équipements n'ont pas toujours été
entretenus convenablement et pour
certains sont déficients aujourd'hui
l'Allemagne est donc pas en mesure de
mener les opérations extérieures la
France elle est capable
militaire opéré en Afrique
aller au levant pour venir des
opérations ça l'armée allemande ne veut
pas le faire aujourd'hui mais c'est pas
le faire les Allemands peuvent avoir
tout de même un rôle à jouer en termes
de nations cadres c'est-à-dire dans
l'encadrement d'une mission militaire à
l'étranger les Français sont nations
cadres de l'OTAN en Roumanie mais les
Allemands sont les central déploiement
de l'OTAN en Lituanie
au même niveau que que les Anglais ou
que les Français en termes de
responsabilité d'encadrement à Berlin
aujourd'hui les mentalités évoluent et
la modernisation de la Bundes verts est
clairement assumée
conscient le monde a changé qu'ils ont
changé et qui ne peuvent pas être
extérieurs au monde un dépliments hyper
contre ce virage il faut revenir
quelques années en arrière en 2014 la
Russie annexe la Crimée
l'OTAN en jouant alors à ces pays
membres et tout spécifiquement à
l'Allemagne d'augmenter son budget de la
défense à 2% de son PIB
cette prise de conscience conduit à
l'adoption d'un livre blanc consacré à
la défense en 2016
en février 2022 la guerre en Ukraine
opère comme un véritable catalyseur
[Musique]
donc les Allemands ont enfin décidé
d'atteindre cet objectif de 2% de leur
PIB et de voter un son spécial 200
milliards d'euros pour rattraper tout le
roi qu'ils ont accumulé dans leur armée
sur les performances de leur matériel le
renouvellement la maintenance donc c'est
fort mais qui va seulement permettre
peut-être à l'environnement de rattraper
un retard accumulé depuis des années
d'euros seront décaissés progressivement
les prévisions de dépenses reflètent les
priorités définies par les États ma
tout d'abord plus d'un tiers de ce
budget sera dédié au renouvellement de
l'aviation les Allemands devaient
renouveler leur aviation qui était
vieillissant
une contrainte qui est liée donc alors
lien avec les États-Unis qui ont une des
bases en Allemagne et dans ses bases
américaines il y a l'arme nucléaire mais
qui peut être qui doit être emporté par
des avions pilotés par des Allemands et
donc pour que ces pour que ces avions
allemands puissent remporter la bombe il
fallait absolument c'est une contrainte
américaine jeter des avions
20 milliards au commandement et à la
numérisation des forces 17 milliards
seront destinés au matériel terrestre
notamment pour l'achat du véhicule
blindé Puma et pour les développe
à terme l'armée allemande pourrait donc
devenir la première armée
conventionnelle en Europe c'est en tout
cas l'objectif affiché du chancelier
Olaf souls d'un point de vue
diplomatique elle devra peut-être se
positionner clairement en termes de
stratégie notamment à l'échelle
européenne
jusqu'à présent l'Allemagne a toujours
affiché une forme de vassalité à l'égard
des États-Unis réaffirmé dans ce
processus de modernisation la décision
de l'achat du F35 c'est une façon à la
fois de se donner d'un matériel qui à
part a priori présenterait toutes les
garanties pour pouvoir le faire c'est en
tout cas qui est certifié pour pouvoir
le faire et en même temps c'est un geste
de réassurance vis-à-vis des États-Unis
mais sur le plan européen quelques
différents ont éloigné l'Allemagne de la
France partenaire jusqu’à leur
privilégié dernier exemple en date le
bouclier antimicile skyfield en octobre
dernier 14 pays européens ont ratifié à
l'initiative de l'Allemagne un accord
pour développer un bouclier antimissiles
sur le flanc Est de l'Europe ces États
ont acheté du matériel déjà existant
américain ou israéliens la France elle a
refusé de signer ce
traités
des Français qui veulent avoir une
défense souveraine de et les Allemands
qui on apprend financière ils ont de
l'argent à dépenser donc ils sont prêts
de dépenser tout de suite pour acquérir
des systèmes même si ceux-ci sont
étrangers
[Musique]